well i wasn't expecting matpat
and the crew at film theory to put
together a squid game video a squid
theory
what everyone got wrong about squid game
let's see
what he
has
to say okay i think my head are your
ears going up and down when that happens
no let's do it john
let's let's do it yeah let's do it you
and me
do it with each other
[Music]
you're thrown into a series of six
mystery games with 400 other players a
pot of 44 million dollars is online but
more importantly if you lose you die
other channels have covered the tactics
to winning the specific games and
honestly the show itself does a pretty
darn good job of showing you creative
solutions to its various puzzles but
today we're gonna help you survive when
you're going in blind just like the
contestants this is how to survive the
squid game
mild spoiler warning for some of the
games and strategies hello internet
welcome to film theory i finally got
around to watching squid game along with
most of the rest of the us at this point
and i loved the series it was tense it
was clever it was also completely
misunderstood by everyone watching it
you see the thing is being called the
next hunger games the new battle royale
the cinematic version of fall guys the
thing is these comparisons really miss
the mark because fundamentally this
isn't how the games in the show work
this dude just called out like a
gazillion breakdown every breakdown
every every channel he just called out
everyone yeah you're trying to start
your own real life squid game amongst
all three youtubers backpacks each other
a lot be careful man heavy spoilers
coming at you if you're one of the
people making that comparison it's
likely gonna get you killed don't worry
most of the characters in the series
phones are the same trap and uh let's
just say it didn't end well for him but
have no fear matpat is here by the time
you're done with this video you'll
understand the real way to survive the
six rounds of playground games
regardless of what individual challenges
you're faced with so the next time some
random guy in the subway offers me a
hundred thousand won to flip his paper
square or when season 2 finally launches
because let's face it this smash hit is
absolutely getting itself a secret
you'll be prepared to survive the squid
so pay attention the information today
might just save your life and make you
rich in the process for the 10 of you
out there who still haven't watched
squid game here's the briefest of
summaries just so you get through
today's theory dion is a down on his
luck gambler who's in dire need of some
cash he's got loan sharks after him his
mother can't afford her surgery and on
top of that he's going to lose custody
of his daughter because he can't afford
to pay a lawyer he agrees to play the
highest stakes game imaginable he's
whisked away to a remote island with
over 400 other competitors where in
order to win they have to survive six
different children's games some of them
are pass fail challenges like red light
green light where failure results in
execution others are player versus
player games like tug of war where the
losing team falls to their death as for
why you'd possibly want to risk your
life in a game like this well each death
adds a hundred million won to the prize
pool 100 million won can you believe
that now all of you are scrambling to
google for that conversion rate
when i was watching the show and so did
everyone else based on the google trends
search results
it actually amounts to about 84 000 per
death considering that there are 456
contestants you're talking about a
potential prize pool of 38 million
dollars but be warned once you start
playing you're not allowed to stop
playing and those who do refuse to play
have to worry about clause number two
consent form clause 2 a player who
refuses to play will be eliminated when
they say elimination they mean a bullet
and your head intersecting in an
unpleasant way the only way out once the
games have started is consent form
clause 3. if all the players are
creating the dub the games are allowed
to end that's actually the job solution
by the way it's if the majority of
players vote to end the game that's why
subs are always better than dubs you
would not believe the rgb or their
witness to it i got to a major argument
with someone in a car right the other
day aaron alexander who watched this
dub and i was going through here's why
especially for live action you gotta
watch it in subs i even heard that there
are some mistranslations that happen in
the dub and bam i hope you're watching
it i hope you're happy ass out [ __ ] but
if you watched it in dub and still love
the show i'm really happy for you i just
wanted it's really just the air and i'm
attacking not not the rest of you so
anyway with the rules laid out let's get
to the strategy like i mentioned before
the players don't know what games
they're going to be playing until they
get to the death island if they're
observant they can piece together clues
based on the wall decorations around
them but still it's not going to give
them much time to prepare or practice
and so that's what we're going to assume
today that we've just signed up and have
no idea what's in store for us in this
massive game of death what should our
general strategies be first we shouldn't
assume that just because people are
dying that this is a death game because
it's not the rule states everyone here
will participate in six different games
those who win all six games will receive
a handsome cash prize if you survive you
win and sure well each death boosts the
pot it's not like a battle royale or
hunger games scenario where there can
only be one left standing here there can
be more than one winner and that's
important it means that the survival of
one person or even a group of people is
not directly negative to your personal
survival which then opens up the
question should you be sabotaging your
fellow players in order to lose the
prize pot and advancing yourself this is
the dilemma that actually pops up
repeatedly throughout the series in the
second game song figures out the game
before anyone else does punching a shape
out of a fragile honeycomb candy knowing
this he immediately chooses the easiest
shape and then encourages the other
players on his team to split up getting
them to take shapes that are much more
difficult and much more likely to lead
to their elimination i would argue
though that some of those games are
intentionally designed to eliminate
other people right i feel like the last
half tug of war the marbles game
especially is all about you the other
person's uh undoubtedly going to die
whoever loses yeah some of these are
designed to eliminate the pool by half
it's not just your own choice honestly
here's the funny part is even the actual
squid game i'm a little bit confused how
many people could be left standing by
the end yeah it seems like you would
have to have either multiple squid games
each with one winner or just it
ultimately comes down to one person gets
to the head of the squid yeah yeah yeah
so it's still designed to kill eliminate
it really feels that way that was part
of what i was feeling throughout the
show is like can we have more than one
and it seems like they really want them
to come just come back to one obviously
there's all kinds of moral and ethical
reasons why you shouldn't intentionally
try to kill other people but what
songwriters
is one of the stupidest moves that we
see anyone make across the entire series
the people he chooses to sabotage are
people that have agreed to team up with
him the players who in the event of a
fight are more likely to have his back
as opposed to say planting a knife
between his shoulder blades oh wait
that's exactly what we see happen they
come to his rescue the following night
when everyone tries killing each other
but teaming up isn't just about keeping
people in your personal alliance safe
keeping more players in the game for
longer means more chances for other
people to help you survive again take
that honeycomb game as the example in it
players are given a needle to punch out
their shape which is fine for easy
shapes like a triangle but not very
effective for the more fragile shapes
like the umbrella or star however one
person in the group our hero guillain
out of desperation comes up with a
completely out of the box strategy
ignoring the needle entirely and licking
the candy so the shape can pop out this
in turn saves multiple other contestants
who copy the strategy people who
otherwise would have been eliminated
just like the rest that's why it's
stupid when the players try to kill each
other between games two and three
because these are men whose lives were
you know what they say two heads are
better than one so 50 heads should be
even better and 400 heads is even better
than that it's why the internet hive
mind is so good at solving puzzles
everyone brings their own experiences
and expertise to the table so let's just
say that you were i don't know faced
with a challenge that involves jumping
across panels of glass with 50 of those
panels being tempered and safe to stand
on well it would be really helpful if
the group had someone who was a glass
expert that could tell the difference
between tempered and untempered glass oh
wait that's exactly what happens except
instead of sharing his knowledge the
glass expert hides this fact until the
end after practically all the other
players have died this is stupid not
just from a statistical angle but also
from a strategic one considering that
most of the games are timed everyone
else realizing that they're just blindly
guessing on a coin flip that could cost
him their life wastes time he would have
to know how to communicate to people on
how to read the glass right properly
because at the end of the day even if he
wanted to help he's still close to the
end of the of the line because you got
to go in order of the glass jumping game
don't you so i guess the question is
like for someone like me i feel like if
you were trying to tell me how to
understand how to read the difference
between the classes i still want to know
how to do it and then also too you would
think that he's got to be close enough
to each pane of glass if he's going to
assess any of them so like he's not
going to be useful from a distance yeah
yeah exactly yeah unless of course like
the players ahead of him are trying to
state what they see looks different or
something like that yeah they're like
calling back and forth maybe he can
still guide them in a way but then they
would just turn the lights out like they
did exactly yeah and then they're like
oh this guy knows glass yeah i have that
you know but point being they didn't
know they would do that so that's true
there are variables here layers to this
[ __ ] every second that you're hiding
your knowledge is a second that the
group isn't making progress as a result
our glass maker despite having the
knowledge that should have kept him
alive through this challenge ultimately
dies because he runs out of time had he
shared it from the get-go mostly
everyone could have survived what was
one of the most disastrous and difficult
challenges of the batch also can i just
digress here for a minute this one
bothered me i just didn't really like
this challenge i get that it was a cool
visual and interesting concept but the
challenge just didn't work for me it
didn't seem to be based on a playground
game like all the others the game makers
cheat by turning off the lights midway
through which directly counteracts their
whole everyone has a fair chance motto
the whole putting people into a specific
order felt unfair and then the way they
conclude it with a giant explosive
finale puts everyone's lives at risk it
was just good spectacle but also
something that felt kind of cheap all
right rant over of course there is the
elephant in the room every player who
doesn't have more money
but that's the wrong way to think about
it let's assume that like we see in the
show there are six rounds and that there
will be at least three games that
require 50 of the players to be
eliminated this would be games like tug
of war and marbles where some amount of
death is guaranteed that means that your
portion of the prize pod is already
gonna be sitting at a hefty 800 million
won 668 000 us dollars even before any
additional deaths from the other games
if you're someone like dion who has loan
sharks to pay off a family member
surgery to pay for and an ex-spouse to
fight in court that amount should cover
everything while still leaving you with
enough to make a down payment on a new
house there's also an economic principle
of diminishing utility which states that
if someone is down on their luck having
an extra eighty thousand dollars is a
huge huge massive deal if you're guillan
that money has a lot of use but if
you're already standing to win over six
hundred thousand dollars another 80k on
top is certainly nice but no longer is
the life-changing sum of money that it
once was once your basic needs are
getting your income increases you gain a
correspondingly smaller and smaller
increase in your life satisfaction yet a
slightly nicer car a slightly nicer
house therefore it's not something
that's worth risking your life over this
is surprisingly a topic that the last
episode focuses on though for spoiler
reasons i'm not gonna play the clip now
don't get me wrong i'm not saying that
any winner of the squid games shouldn't
have that money but what i am saying is
that there's a tipping point where each
additional dollar earned is less and
less worth risking your own life to
achieve and by just playing the game
with survival as your first priority you
wind up with plenty of money to change
your situation while also minimizing
your risk of losing that life so you
know you can go on and spend it in terms
of law of diminishing utility i feel
like that's kind of the point of the
show i get it that these characters
don't have money and they're desperate
the more the merrier it sounds like you
know but i i think in real life though
too it is about trying to constantly
surpass what it depends on the context
you look at it and if you look at it
like getting a high out of how much
you're earning you know people get
addicted to that like enough is never
enough that's kind of the point it's
easy to be very think it's much easier
to be logical about it when you're doing
the 80 000 thing i think no matter how
much money you get most people vast
majority like if you're if you have the
opportunity to truly get more you're
you're going to go after that more yeah
i think most people would be like as
much money as i could get on there i'll
take i think that's just the way people
operate i feel like that's kind of the
part of the conversation the show is
like with the spoiler of the finale i'm
gonna spoil it yeah they get bored so
they made this game yeah don't worry
that would be me in the squid game okay
like you know what that's enough money
for me i'm just gonna help you guys
i don't know i got enough if i make it
through yeah just let me be alive and
i'll help you out obviously there's
gonna be rounds where you're forced to
fight for your life and eliminate other
players but if you don't have to kill
people then don't never thought that's a
sentence i'd have to say but here we are
but there is one big concern that you
have to be aware of clause number three
at any point the players can vote on
whether or not to end the game if the
majority of players want out that causes
the game to end not just for them but
for everyone in order for you to walk
home with your money you have to
complete six games but people will
probably vote to escape the games if
they're put into a position where
they're almost certainly gonna die so
with that in mind let's go back to the
glass bridge unless you have outside
knowledge of what tempered and
untempered glass looks like the game is
generally decided by random coin flips
and by coin flips i mean the first few
people in line coming down with a mild
case of death for the good of the group
in the challenge there are 18 sets of
panels worst case scenario you have 18
deaths the best case scenario is zero
deaths with the person in front
correctly guessing every time but fat
chance there as player number three
correctly estimates when he's three
panels in probability there i'll get
everything right hey you got this one in
32 768. overall if you're first in line
you have a one in
262
144 chance of survival the average here
is nine different i like those uh
distribution curve basically looking
like a bell curve which you can see
using any binomial visualization tool
yep have one of those handy right using
that probability chart we can see that
six people in line are basically screwed
having less than a 5 chance to survive
while the people going 13th and later
have a 95 or better chance to survive
but even if you're trapped in the game
with no calculator it doesn't take a
whole lot of brain power to determine
that you do not want to be one of the
first nine people to play so you as a
smart player hopefully chose not to be
one of the first few people in line but
even if you're feeling good about your
odds of survival remember that for you
to actually make it across the bridge
you need the game to happen let's say
that the game has been reduced to 13
players and you're lucky enough to be
13th in line that's good news for you
you have 95 odds to survive however you
probably won't make it across the bridge
for the simple reason that there are
good odds that the first seven people in
line are going to nope the heck out of
there going with the majority of them in
the game meaning that even though you
had the ideal position and would have
won you get nothing good day sir and you
see this is exactly what could have
happened in the show 16 players
remaining knowing that the first nine
were likely to die they could have voted
to end the game right then and there and
because they were in the majority clause
number three would have been enacted
game over now let's take the alternate
scenario let's assume knowledge was
shared and everyone's cooperating at
this point there would have been two 50
elimination games tug of war and marbles
in the best case scenario 456 players
would have been reduced to 114.
by the time you get to the bridge even
if every single one of those first 18
people in line got cold feet they
wouldn't have enough votes to end the
game and instead of most of them being
wiped out we'd expect an average of nine
of those players or eight percent of the
114 player group to get eliminated
chances of survival increase the more
people are around you to take the blows
so now that we've spent a lot of time
talking about what not to do i will say
he has made a compelling fantastic
argument for why it would be actually
pretty great to try to keep as many
people alive as possible when everyone
in the show most seem to be pretty
insistent on killing as many people as
possible
it's exactly like saw five all along we
were supposed to work together saw five
survival of the fittest of the software
spoilers if you want to keep that one a
surprise because it is the best of the
best
the best one what can you do to increase
your odds of surviving in squid game
apart of course from playing nice with
your fellow competitors well the first
one is obvious don't panic red light
green light is an easy game and the
timer was very generous as long as you
stay calm and you use your time wisely
also just like with the three clauses
make sure that you're paying attention
to the game's rules for instance we see
song woo cheat at marbles by
misdirecting his partner but his method
for collecting 20 marbles doesn't
actually involve breaking any of the
rules that are established by the game
master the player who manages to take
all ten marbles from their partner
repeatedly throughout the series we see
players presented with an obvious
solution like the needle in the
honeycomb game and they just assume that
because this is the default or
recommended way to play the game it must
therefore be the only way to play the
game but rarely is that the case you can
lie to your partner and take his marbles
you can lick your candy until the sugar
melts the problem everyone falls into is
that they assume certain rules are there
when in fact they're not in the glass
bridge episode we see that guillain was
able to take a single marble as a
keepsake with him which ended up being
relevant in that very game a second
third or 20 more marbles could have come
in real handy with that one also with
that glass bridge the rules just state
that you have to jump from panel to
panel for this game you will guess which
one of the next two tiles is the tile
made of the stronger tempered glass and
only step on those across the 18 pairs
of tiles but nothing said that you had
to land on the middle of each panel
landing with your feet and the
supporting bars holding up the glass is
going to reduce the weight on that glass
ultimately helping resist the breakage
is it breaking the rules i don't know
honestly i don't think so but here's the
thing you know that you're gonna die if
you choose wrong so why not try pushing
the edges of the rules just a little bit
when there's nothing else to lose by
taking a moment to think about the
actual hard rules of the game and not
automatically dismissing unconventional
solutions by assuming that anything else
isn't allowed you might actually be able
to find the loophole that allows you to
survive lastly use your surroundings not
only are the walls giving you clues but
your clothes the bed the springs and the
mattresses all of it could potentially
prove useful were you given a glass
bottle yesterday as a part of your meal
instead of breaking it to try and shank
your opponents why not bring it with you
to your next game tug of war throw it
onto your opponent's platform to throw
them off or put glass under their feet
maybe cut the rope so neither side loses
another thing that i want to get off my
chest this is just a terrible idea i
think that doll senses when you move
around that person
is going to stop at times that you don't
expect or anticipate if they get shot
that bullet might go through them and
pierce you or their dead body might
knock into you instead of focusing on
the game itself you're gonna be focused
on another person as you run down that
field which is not where your attention
needs to be in short your number one
strategy to surviving the sweet game
should be to ignore sung woo i think he
would put us at a disadvantage if we
just choose one although i don't recall
in red light green light anyone who did
that hid behind others that they got
shot shot his strategy there worked out
also you got to get yourself a little
guy from pakistan to help you that's
right you just need a selfless
compassionate angel of a player right
behind you and you'll be fine with
amazing physical strength for someone of
his stature yeah his one arm is just
like the strongest for being the
smartest person in the room all of his
ideas are dumb i guess except for the
tug of war game anyway if you happen to
meet a well-dressed man in a train
station who invites you to throw squares
of paper at each other now you know what
to do and that's to say no because
unless you desire to win more than half
a million dollars is greater than your
desire to have more than a 12 percent
chance of surviving the next week of
your life it's not going to be worth it
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and here's a game for you press
that subscribe button as fast as you can
see how many times you can press it
before this video ends maybe you'll end
up subscribed to this channel maybe you
won't we'll find out together it'll give
me the weirdest data for unsub to resub
to a video of all time
i kind of want people to do that now
like i want to see that report he could
have gotten 500 000 more subscribers if
he didn't encourage him to play 500
what are the odds that your sub account
will increase
all right guys hell that was uh that was
awesome that was awesome yeah make it
make a really good argument for
absolutely puts it into a different
different light here
all right guys well subscribe to film
theory if you haven't done so already
you can subscribe to us hit that like
button and hey let's do a p
jean jeter i would love to be in the
squid game with you you know what i
would really love if we were in the
squid game with everyone you photograph
because
believe me
we would make sure all of them would
survive yeah we would help out only
eliminate the ones who are not as
attractive as that we would go who are
the top 114 hottest models that gene
has here and let's focus on eliminating
the others yeah yeah this would also
ensure my chances that they would not
try to eliminate my shallow self that's
right because you're clearly working
clearly you're the one for contingency
of gene's collaborators and they will of
course appreciate your intentions of
doing that that i am slowly going off of
physical looks here that would be a
first for the vips based off of
your
your clientele competing in the game the
sexiest squid game we've ever had
i'm glad he's keeping the hot ones he's
alive yeah i hope this alba guy makes it
through the game it's kind of telling
that there's only 114 male models here
bring them to my quarters
anyway gene i hope you get invited in
and i hope they let you choose i hope
that you tell them all your models are
financially struggling right now so they
choose that
[Music]